I didn't buy the cow for a bribe
usman's mom is looking like child please
after Kim breaks down in tears in front
of the family when they accuse her of
trying to buy their blessing I am not
that kind of person then his mom gets up
and walks off in the middle of the
conversation she wants you guys out
okay and I'm not mad at her do what you
have to do ma'am but Kim is all of this
really worth it no hell no the stress
the drama the pain all to hear something
like this come out of usman's mouth I
have a adventure truck beautiful and
sexy women around me I'm rejecting it
because I feel like it shouldn't be
beauty or whatever you should be loved
somebody ugly in the heart I know that
hurt
that's a thing to say to me after I get
out of here that's something to say oh
we have a lot to talk about let's get
into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's malicio I know
many of you if not majority of you are
over Angela and her Antics I am too
trust and believe but there's more
before we get into Kim and Usman let me
give you a quick update on where she and
Michael stand
I'm getting on my plane no [ __ ] you
after Angelo walks up on Michael because
he refuses to show her his phone what am
I supposed to think
are you scamming me are you cheating on
me you're doing something hey
follows behind her hungry
Michael
yeah I need to talk to you Andrew
I go I don't want to talk right now you
need to talk why you don't follow me you
are my wife I'm not ready for this yet
I'm not I didn't want to be here Michael
you know you know I love you no I don't
know you love me
no Michael didn't pull out the you know
I love you right you know you know I
love you no I don't know you love me why
did you think it was going to happen
when you put Instagram up tell me
Michael finally gives Angela to calm
down a bit and take a seat and he tries
to explain to her that he's on Instagram
because he wants to make money she's not
giving him much anymore and she's also
not allowing him to work not allowing
him
if I make use of
my social media
for influencing I get paid I have no
choice than to start making money on my
own because as a 24 years old man in
Nigeria I'm expected to take care of my
family of course Angela isn't hearing
any of that is
and you start to see her boiling back up
again oh here we go but what comes next
y'all
it's one of the worst moments that I've
seen on the show we've been we've been
waiting
about no money [ __ ] calm down
money [ __ ]
of course notes that was so bad calm
down [ __ ]
Angela needs a
reality check and I only say that
because I can't say what I really want
to say if we're here we're here you
don't talk to people like that there's
no reason
about no money [ __ ] and the sad part
about it is that she has no clue that
all that Venom she's spitting out calm
down
money [ __ ]
is going to do nothing but come right
back to her Point Blank period this is
abuse and I honestly don't know how much
longer it's going to be able to fly on
90 day it's awful no longer can we chop
it up to oh this is how Angela is no for
her own sake like I said she needs a
reality check hopefully seeing these
moments played back will somewhat do
that for her Fame is not worth being
known for this type of behavior and if
it's that hard for you to be in control
of your emotions
it's time for you to go seek some extra
help and once again I agree with the
number of you who say if a male was
talking to a woman like this
they will be out of there
it's terrible she hopped up with I don't
know what type of stance this is looking
as if she was about to fight Michael and
he's so embarrassed he covers his face
but you know what you know what the wild
part about all of this is is that
Michael continues the conversation as if
what we just saw didn't happen it's
become so normal to him
he doesn't need to make money off of
social media because really how much
money is he gonna make you've got to be
I don't know how to say this without
being rude don't worry about being rude
now you've got to be I don't know how to
say this without being rude but
interesting
like he doesn't have Charisma and you
know what Michael blocked me on
Instagram so maybe his plan to be an
influencer and make money off of social
media is a cover-up the only reason my
husband Michael would block me is
because he's flirting with women
Angela is going to believe what she
wants to believe regardless of what
Michael says and speaking of Michael
talking up he tells Angela she's worried
about him flirting on social media when
that's what she's been doing dancing
with the quote sexy man on Tick Tock who
she's considering going to see in Canada
this is ridiculous
but we know that already
okay boss if I was the one doing such
that I know you're absolutely right I
try explode can I say why I did that why
it started out two and three videos to
get your attention I've lost weight you
ain't never seen my boobs you're not
seeing my true chain I see nothing don't
tell me you love me and I seen this guy
he's sexy I said Michael's gonna be
jealous if I do it is you know you're
gonna tell me stop now don't do that
take it down that's what I thought
but
you didn't respond Angela goes on to
change the subject by telling Michael
that she has a secret which is that his
Visa should be coming in any day now yep
she dangles that carrot in front of his
face your Visa is about here
and you oh you found Andrew
Lou said you're about here why is she
screaming Lou said you're about here and
you know what he told me also
if we're having problems now would you
join his IG
you knew that would upset me thought for
the worst for the reasons
don't talk like that because of
Instagram come on that's what you need
to ask yourself you need to put
Instagram down because you want to
because you love me and it's hurting me
of course I do love you
then you show me
Angela goes on to give Michael an
ultimatum if you want to be an
opportunist you be that
but you won't be with me he either gets
off Instagram by the morning or she's
done wow the double-edged sword of
social media it connected them and now
it might be the very thing that leads to
their divorce
we are in a new age y'all we are in a
new age but side note I will admit
Michael confuses me okay this is what
I'm thinking one of three things is
happening here one he genuinely Loves
Angela and he's in it for her two he
genuinely Loves Angela and he's in it
for her
and America three
he's in it for America and
I've been leaning toward two and three
lately because I don't understand why he
would take all of this without there
being some reward he feels like it's
worth it yes there are people who
struggle with low self-esteem and allow
others to treat them poorly because of
it but I personally don't think that's
fully the case with Michael
either way whether he's sincere and in
it for Angela or in it for the states or
both I hope he knows that there is no
place no thing no person that is worth
his dignity he deserves respect your
partner should never speak to you like
this calm down
money [ __ ] and he's not doing her any
good by accepting it I'm going Mike let
me take you to no I got it
me
well he's back to calling her babe
I'll see you tomorrow
so long
to get an update about my Visa
but what's the point of going to America
and Avenue treats me this way there too
I want my voice to be heard I don't want
to be a silent partner
sometimes I just feel I should just let
go of everything and just both of us
should move on with our lives
but I'm getting tired of it all honestly
that's the car she started tearing apart
yep well hopefully Michael is serious
and he's really considering what life
would be like living with her in America
in Hazelhurst Georgia at that we'll see
what happens next week with those two as
the saga continues all right time to get
into Usman and Kim she goes through it
this episode
mom's house to get her blessing for them
to get married and things go south after
usman's family accuses Kim of trying to
bribe them after she buys his mom a cow
as a gift
the cow didn't even help me they think
I'm being disrespectful and I'm trying
to bribe them usman's brother reveals
usman's ex-wife Lisa also bought them an
animal if I can't change their opinion
of me then I don't think I'll ever get
this blessing and I will never get a
second chance so what do I do now you
know let the tears flow Kim let the
tears flow I really wish
that you can get to know me for who I am
everything I do is from my heart people
that know me would die if they thought
that you would that you that your family
would think I would bribe somebody how
dare you say that
I just say anything is a broad
experience
but that's not my problem
I am not that kind of person and if you
don't agree with me and you'll never
accept me that's fine that's perfectly
fine I'll go home usman's brother who
looks very nice by the way seems so
concerned I wonder what he's thinking I
know I'm not the perfect woman for him
but the love is there I didn't buy the
cow for a bribe othman's mom is over it
I am not that kind of person some might
see this as a form of a bribe if we want
to get technical
Merriam-Webster defines bribe as quote
something that serves to induce or
influence
and yes the cow is a gift to increase
the chances of them accepting her but I
personally wouldn't classify it as a
bribe only because I know that Kim's
heart is in the right place I make him
happy I know that's hard to believe I'm
willing to accept
so much because I make him happy okay
I'm willing to let him take a second
wife usman's mom responds by saying she
wouldn't be opposed to him and Kim
getting married if Usman marries a
younger woman from his land first and
has a child with her in my head I'm like
hell no well usman's mom is standing on
what she said and as of right now she
tells them they don't have her blessing
she also tells them it's time for them
to go yeah
she don't think she will continue
listening to you guys but you guys
should just go and leave her first
that she wants you guys out okay once
they get back to where they're staying
Usman tells Kim he's not giving up so
he's gonna try to set up another meeting
with his mom Kim also hammers home the
fact that she is not open to being a
second wife but I can't make any more
exceptions because I have exactly what I
want now like his love and I feel like
the love for he has for me now would
change with that
getting the title of the first wife is
so important to me because in previous
relationships I always came second
always I was always pushed to the side
and I'm not going to let that happen to
me again I don't care if he came here
right now and proposed me with the
biggest diamond in the world I'm not a
second sorry I can't I know my worth
well usman's actions are about to test
him to see if she really does know her
worth
listen to this man's plan I'm going to
call my mom if my mom say okay it was
one we are going to meet then there's
tendency that's possibility that is Hope
and if Mom said that she will never ever
let me get married to Kimberly first
may like be accepted she may not say yes
but if it keeps on going Kimberly will
say okay if that's the only way let's
just do it as long as you are not going
to leave me
see this is called taking advantage of
someone's kindness and taking advantage
of someone's loyalty Usman knows that
being a second wife is not what Kim
wants but he's going to try to coerce
her into it that's so selfish you know
what I think while Kim is looking for a
whole husband and Usman he wants to keep
her around as his wife because she makes
him feel like an international Superstar
I super fun don't call me that she is
his hype man
and let's be clear there are some people
who will only want you around because
you make them feel good about themselves
these ain't opinions these are facts and
based off this conversation they have
the next day where he tries to bring up
her being a second wife again it seems
like the gift that Usman thinks he's
giving him in this relationship
is the mere fact that he's with her we
have a plan and I'm not going to
differentiate from that plan I am not
going to be your second wife I refuse
that and if I leave here single I leave
here single I love you and I'll be
heartbroken very very nice
sir but like you're telling me that I
cannot be second but no compromise I've
been compromising more than what you
compromise you're not compromising
anything to me I compromise more than
you
I think I have done what I have never
done in my life
saying that after I tell the whole world
that I'm not going to be with any other
lady and here I am well look Usman no
one told you to lie or to speak too soon
he's gaslighting Kim ever since that's
become such a buzzword I realize how
many people actually do it he's trying
to manipulate him into thinking she
hasn't compromised enough making her
question her own sanity when she's done
more than enough she has spent so much
money to come see you she left her
mother who was sick rest her soul to see
Usman and she's allowing a second wife
when we know she is going to have an
extremely hard time with that
broke up me hey you can go
I'm telling you you can go I have
Advantage than anyone that I'm going to
be with I have adventure to have
beautiful and sexy women around me I'm
rejecting them because I feel like it
shouldn't be beauty or whatever you
should be loved some are ugly in the
heart
then maybe you should compete with
animals
if that's what you want to find then
tell him if you break up at your age at
my age you tell me to break up if you
break up you think I have anything to
regret
I mean
can anybody see it
seriously
understandably Kim goes back to her room
and cries her eyes out
that's a funny thing to say to me after
I get out of here that's something to
say and I'm tired of the little comments
he can say whatever he wants I can't
like he's doing me a favor
talking about he can have a hundred at
this time like I'm some ugly [ __ ] let
him find one that's as good as I am let
him fight when this is as oil as I am
and for saying that in my opinion it
seems as if at some point Kim started to
base her self-worth on if she could get
Usman I mean I've done it before I'm
sure some of you have as well so where
you tell yourself whether subconsciously
or consciously if I get this person that
confirms that I am worthy I am good
enough
and sometimes because we don't want to
feel the rejection we force things to
happen and end up denying our needs and
wants just to get that person which is
ultimately not smart because once you
get them you're not going to be happy
you've already put everything to the
side that would truly make you happy and
you've given all your power to another
human being
okay
Kim doesn't deserve this and I hope she
starts to put herself first and accept
that she's worthy and she doesn't need
Usman or Soulja Boy to confirm that I
don't even think I want the blessing now
I just don't even think I just don't
care oh it might be time for another cam
chat soon let me know if you have some
questions for her below alright next
week it seems as if Kim is going to hold
her ground
why are you telling me that you want to
break up with me in my hometown but I
was telling you what my boundary was
I've dealt with this in past
relationships and I will never ever in
my life let a man manipulate me again
I'm glad she's calling it what it is
police she does not go backwards okay 90
day fans fam make sure you stick with
E.T because we are covering it all I
will see you next time
[Music]